you know the trick to the British accent
is not to open your mouth later dude
later dude well I bet you also the
sounds come out because their teeth are
all different angle so probably the
sound comes out different probably I
think they keep their mouth shut a
little more when we do and I think they
talk like this a little more than we do
that's maybe the best English accent
I've ever done yeah it's better when you
say peaky blonders pey [__]
blinds but when did you put your glasses
on uh I feel
better when I don't feel well I put my
sunglasses on a lot I know I know guys
when I'm sick in bed I'm wearing
sunglasses are you actually yeah I don't
like the light just cover your face you
have a snor do you have a snor mask uh
I'm in the podcast Studio I want cover
my [__] face great if you just did
the podcast with your eyes closed for
the rest of it dude with that [__]
Vis that VI you know that visor with the
mirror I saw somebody wearing one of
those on our walk today I was like are
you welding what's the deal yeah you
should just you should just sit there
and just try and do it with your eyes
closed the entire time okay
ready all right
okay what if I what if I did the English
accent with my eyes
closed what do you like the Michael
Jordan of accents now get it because he
shot a free throw with his eyes closed
yeah but the Michael Jord I don't know
yeah yeah he's got no situational
awareness of this going to be pretty
funny well I I okay I'll just do the
rest of the Pod like this can't wait do
it later dude with a British accent
later
dude later dude no that wasn't bad okay
yeah like like a like a like like later
dude that was Australian later dude
later dude later dude later dude